you are looking right now at Pittsburgh
which is where ubers secret self-driving
test facilities located we got an
exclusive look inside it
uber showed us how it's trying to make
self-driving technology safer now this
comes after a series of delays and
setbacks including a deadly accident
last year involving an autonomous
vehicle Kris Van Cleave is in Washington
with more on this story so Chris water
overs plans good morning to you
well good morning uber is betting its
self-driving car future in part on this
vehicle we'll show you more of it here
in just a minute but let's make a little
bit of news uber says it plans to resume
its on-street testing in San Francisco
and Toronto by the end of the year it is
part of a crawl walk run approach to
self-driving that Hooper says grows out
of its renewed focus on safety okay here
comes a pedestrian driving down
make-believe Lane is what uber hopes is
a very real future this is uber
self-driving test track in Pittsburgh
the roads draw their names from the
famous pittsburgh-based kids program mr.
Rogers neighborhood but what's happening
here is far from child's play we took a
ride with the project's chief scientist
raquel artisan is this car as good of a
driver as the average human is kids on
this 54 acre closely guarded facility
uber is building its return to
autonomous driving after the March 2018
crash where a self-driving Ober hit and
killed a woman crossing a street in
Tempe Arizona there's a lot of
skepticism about self-driving cars and
in the aftermath of that accident
there's more skepticism about uber and
self-driving cars so how are you going
to convince me or my mother that she
should get in the back of one it's by
demonstration it's by showing that the
system works it's by not saying it but
proving it
Erik may offer leads ubers autonomous
driving unit after ubers fatal accident
the number of people who said they were
afraid to ride in a self-driving car
rose to 71 percent from 63 percent a
year ago do you think the improvements
to the technology are such that
that kind of accident wouldn't happen
again I think that yes it's a little
enthusiastic and maybe presumptuous to
think that there will never be an
accident in a self-driving car it's
inevitable and there will be the fatal
crash halted ubers self-driving program
as the company conducted a top-to-bottom
safety review they added a second safety
driver and technology to monitor them
for distraction
uber resumed limited on-road testing in
Pittsburgh last December but most of the
development work is happening here on
the site of an old steel mill Stephen
lash oversaw the new cars design so this
is the brain of the car this is the
brain of the car it's actually hidden
underneath this this plate here and
there's a there's liquid cooling beneath
it to keep the computer cool uber
promises even if the computer is doing
the driving the ultimate control will be
at the passenger's fingertips
so there's button right here actually
that you can press and then the computer
will immediately find a safe place to
pull the car over so it'll be just hit
the button let me out and right now the
car is driving itself
yeah the cars are cautious they operate
at 25 miles an hour or less allowing
more decision time sometimes more than a
human driver would need even uber admits
they sometimes fail tests our approach
isn't going to be it's ready hey
everybody it's ready trust us our
approach is it's not ready yet this
vehicle is not ready yet we believe that
this vehicle can do it but today it
isn't there Tim Stevens from CNET's road
show self-driving technology is
absolutely fundamental to ubers business
if they cannot get drivers out of cars
they probably will never be profitable
enough to be a viable business already
competitor wham-o is offering a limited
autonomous ride-hailing service in
arizona drive AI has a shuttle service
running in Texas and Ford is testing on
the streets of Miami there are
approximately 40,000 traffic deaths in
the US every year the promise of the
self-driving car is the possibility they
could reduce or eliminate the 94 percent
of crashes caused by human error it's
one of the hardest engineering
challenges of our generation we think of
it as our space program alright here's
another look at this third-generation
autonomous vehicle for uber it'll be the
first one to come
off the line with the intent of being
driven by a computer that means it can
close its own doors it has redundant
braking and steering because one day
there won't be a person on board to do
those things if there's a problem and
most of the sensors except for the thing
up here all the doohickeys that used to
hang off the vehicle are now tucked
inside the car Tony all right Chris
thank you very much you can close its
own doors I wanted to pump its own gas
the key question here I don't think is
not are they perfectly safe but are they
safer than us and the rest and they will
be give it time they will be I think
there's no question about it and I think
in the end the insurance companies are
gonna say to you we can't afford to let
you drive a teenager's get your licenses
while you can right yeah so you both see
the day because I'm so not there yet but
you see the day where one day kids will
say you mean people used to drive yeah I
mean I'm telling my son already you
better start driving now because you
won't have a lot of time then we can all
text and ride yeah